[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public une
semaine où je vous propose de revenir
sur les faits marquants de l'année 2023
les bouleversements économiques ce sera
pour demain l'actualité internationale
on y reviendra mercredi et ce soir notre
bilan politique nos invités on chois les
personnalités et les dates les plus
marquantes comme ce 16 mars où Elisabeth
borne choisit le 493 pour faire passer
sa réforme des retraites c'est sur votre
réforme sur le texte du Parlement fruit
d'un compromis entre les deux assemblées
que je suis prête à engager ma
responsabilité aussi sur le fondement de
l'article 49 aléa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement autre date marquante le 27
juin la mort de Naël et les émeutes qui
ont suivi dans plus de 550 villes de
France avec comme conséquence politique
le rassemblement national et Jordane
Bardella qui font partie des gagnants de
ces 12 derniers mois on verra aussi
comment la nupè S autodétruite et à quel
point Emmanuel Macron et son
gouvernement sont dépendants deslr pour
continuer de réformer le pays car c'est
l'actu de ce 18 décembre la commission
mixte paritaire réunie depuis 17h à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde
attend cette fumée blanche d'une CMP
conclusive fruit des efforts d'Élisabeth
borne pour obtenir l'accord des
parlementaires républicains un échec
est-il encore possible à l'inverse
comment va réagir l'aile gauche des
députés renaissances si le texte se
rapproche trop de celui qui avait été
voté au Sénat la majorité relative
d'Emmanuel Macron peut-elle exploser
avant d'entendre nos experts et nos
envoyés spéciaux ont fait le point sur
les dernières négociations avec Samia de
chia ils se sont retrouvés à 17h à
l'Assemblée nationale SEP députés et SEP
sénateurs chargés de trouver un
compromis sur le projet de loi
immigration l'avenir du texte est
suspendu à un accord entre la majorité
présidentielle et la droite
je sais pas si je suis confiant mais en
tout cas on va tout faire pour qu'il y a
un accord c'est un texte de compromis
j'espère qu'il va en sortir avec des
concessions part et d'autrre et euh
c'est la seule façon d'y arriver dans ce
bras de fer la droite est en position de
force l'Assemblée nationale a rejeté le
projet de loi du gouvernement sans même
l'examiner le seul texte voté par le
Parlement reste celui du Sénat une
version considérablement durci par leslr
qui risque de braquer l'aile gauche du
camp macroniste parmi les principaux
points d'achopement la réforme de l'amee
l'aide médicale d'État pour les
étrangers la droite accepte finalement
de la reporter le gouvernement s'est
engagé à lancer la réforme dans un autre
texte examiné au premier semestre 2024
autre point de friction les prestations
sociales la droite veut exiger des
étrangers qu'il vivent depuis au moins 5
ans sur le sol français pour toucher les
allocations familiales ou encore les
aides au logement là aussi un compromis
semble avoir été trouvé avec la majorité
les républicain avaient évoqué 5 ans
nous on leur a dit attention il y a des
gens qui contribuent à ces allocations
familiale en travaillant c'est pour ça
qu' a une proposition 30 mois pour ceux
qui travaillent 5 ans pour ceux qui
travaillent pas les discussions étaient
plus tendues sur la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers en tension l'aile gauche du camp
macroniste y tenait absolument alors que
la droite en a fait une ligne rouge un
accord serait en bonne voie mais rien
n'était encore finalisé sur ce point
avant le début de la
réunion le gouvernement dans la main des
LR les conséquences politiques de cette
commission mixte paritaire on en débat
avec Laur Salvin bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes directrice générale de verriant
excantar public et vous venez de
réaliser une étude pour la Commission
européenne sur l'opinion publique dans
dans l'Union européenne Bruno cotrez
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes politologue
chercheurs au CNRS et au cvipof
j'accueille Rachel bignas bonjour et ben
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste des questions d'immigration
pour l' hebbdomadaire Marianne Marianne
d'ailleurs qui euh consacre son dernier
numéro à ce thème de l'immigration les
cinq vraies questions pour sortir de
l'impasse Mathieu croisson bonsir
mathieist politique et puis on est en en
direct en duplexe également avec Quentin
calmc qui est à l'Assemblée nationale
pour nous faire vivre voilà cette
commission mixte paritaire on sera on
sera avec vous dans dans un court
instant Quentin mais je voudrais quand
même faire un premier tour de table avec
nos invités ici lors Salvin ceux qui
jouent le plus gros sont peut-être pas à
l'intérieur de la de la CMP de la
commission mixte paritaire je pense à la
première ministre et peut-être à son
ministre de l'Intérieur et puis par
ailleurs aussi à Emmanuel Macron
certainement on peut aller jusque là on
est d'accord je crois que pour pour la
première ministre qui a en plus repris
les reennes sur ce sujet ces derniers
jours c'est vraiment euh alors
aujourd'hui et demain mais bon
effectivement il y a déjà il faut pas
oublier un premier tour qui est
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu énorme de
crédibilité notamment sur la façon de
faire de la politique je crois que c'est
un sujet qui est traité par le
gouvernement depuis plus de 18 mois
sujet de de de l'immigration et on a du
mal à comprendre pourquoi on en arrive
là aujourd'hui dans l'urgence avec
visiblement une pension de séance on ne
sait pas pourquoi peut-être pour des
dernières demanda à Quentin dans un
instant tractation effectivement donc là
c'est vraiment sur la méthode je pense
aussi que Elisabeth borne elle va être
jugée sur la méthode de faire des
politiques publiques aujourd'hui ouais
parce que Bruno cotr c'est dans le
bureau d'Élisabeth borne que tout s joué
depuis depuis 3 4 jours oui tout est
remonté au niveau de Matignon
effectivement alors en partie c'est lié
au fait que les républicains semblent-il
n'avaient pas une confiance optimale
dans le ministre de l'Intérieur donc il
avait remonter à à Matignon vous dites
ça en terme élégant voilà mais aussi on
voit bien parce que ça concerne un
domaine d'action publique régalienne
extrêmement important qu'on imagine mal
que du côté de Matignon on doit pas être
on serait pas au premier rang donc
évidemment donc c'est remonté au niveau
de Matignon c'est effectivement dans le
bureau de la premierre ministre que ces
tractations ont eu ont eu lieu avec un
double signification la signification
effectivement qu'un portage
institutionnel important par la première
ministre mais aussi la première ministre
dans son rôle un de ses rôles principaux
qui est cor coordinatrice animatrice
mais en tout cas coordinatrice de la
majorité parce qu'il va falloir
sacrément serrer les rangs sans aucun
doute demain oui alors ça on ireviendra
un peu plus tard parce que c'est l'un
des enjeux de à la fois de cette fin
d'après-midi et évidemment de la journée
de demain en fonction de ce qui
découlera de cette commission mixte
paritaire Rachel Binas pour il faut
rappeler qu'Élisabeth borne elle vient
quand même de la gauche et et quand on
voit d'après les informations qu'on a ce
ce qui va ressortir de cette CMP et le
contenu de ce texte il y a il y a
quelques coupleœuvre à avaler pour pour
pour la première ministre c'est ça aussi
le bilan de ces derniersr de ces
derniers tout fait pour elle et pour
toute l'aile gauche de la macrony si je
puis dire c'est pour ça que
l'enthousiasme qu'on avait vu lors du
vote de la motion de de Roger était à
prendre à relativiser pour la gauche
c'était une espèce de de victoire à la
pyus alors certes sur le coup en effet
la gifle comme on a expliqué avait été
donné mais en réalité sur le moyen et
long terme c'est peut-être la droite et
également armmanin parce que Gérald
armanin incarne encore hein cette aile
plus à plus à droite il n'a pas rompu
avec ses convictions et avec avec sa
famille d'origine c'est peut-être lui
quelque part qui va qui pourrait en
sortir éventuellement gagnant dans la
mesure où tout à fait ça c'est
intéressant alors qu'on on on on le juge
plutôt affaibli depuis depuis quelques
jours al il est on ne sait pas
exactement quel va être l'issue de de ce
texte toujours est-il que ce texte qui
au départ a été présenté à l'assemblée
de manière un petit peu plus on va dire
à soupliit par rapport à sa version à la
version sénatoriale mais là va revenir
plutôt durci et en cela ça pourrait être
l'échec de l'aile gauche de la macronie
mais aussi de la gauche dans son
ensemble qui n'est pas arrivé justement
à faire de ce texte à le transformer
pour qu'il corresponde à à ses
convictions la gauche relativement
inaudible sur les questions de
d'immigration Quentin Calmet est avec
audre vetaz et redam Rabit au à
l'Assemblée nationale donc tout près de
de la salle où cette commission mixte
paritaire se se
réunit que reste-t-il à négocier on
parlait de de ces rendez-vous qui ont
lieu à Matignon notamment une dernière
fois hier soir ce dimanche soir
qu'est-ce qui reste à
négocier et bien Thomas ça fait même
l'objet d'une suspension de la CMP est
ce qu'il reste à négocier pour vous
placer un petit peu le le décor regardez
sur ces images de redim rabbit
effectivement vous voyez les
journalistes qui sont cantonnés à la
salle des quatre colonnes ça change de
la moquette rouge du Sénat et
effectivement qui sont les députés
sénateurs de la CMP qui sont réunis au
bout du couloir la Réunion qui n'a
toujours pas repris à l'heure où l'on se
parle car elle aura duré au final
quelques minutes 5 minutes 17h
convocation de la SMP 17h05 suspension
de cette réunion car très rapidement un
point a été et bien mis en exerg comme
étant problématique entre Renaissance et
leslr c'est un député d'ailleurs
Renaissance qui est venu nous
l'expliquer ici en salle des quatre
colonnes cela concerne les APL les aides
au logement en urence en cas de
regroupement familial donc un point très
technique de ce texte immigration car
vous le savez dans l'accord qui est en
cours de négociation entre LR et
Renaissance il y a la conditionnalité de
ces allocations à une certaine durée de
présence sur le territoire pour les
étrangers et donc Renaissance veut en
exclure les APL en cas de regroupement
familial et cela coince avec leslr qui
se serait rendu compte de ce point juste
au moment du déclenchement de la réunion
de la SCMP d'où cette suspension
toujours en cours à l'heureù se parle
Thomas merci beaucoup Quentin évidemment
vous nous faites signe on retourne à
l'Assemblée dès qu'il y a du du nouveau
tout au long de de de ce
débat Bruno cotress je reviens vers vous
parce que ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est aussi la conséquence de
cette pression qui a été mise par
Emmanuel Macron sur ellisabeth borne et
et sur ses équipes pour faire une et
aussi sur les parlementaires d'ailleurs
pour pour que cette commission mixte
paritaire se déroule là aussi vite je me
souviens d'hervy Marseille le président
du groupe Union centriste ici Sénat
disant mais non il nous faut du temps
c'est pas un texte si simple à à
discuter dans son ensemble oui parce que
du côté d'Emmanuel Macron sans doute on
on souhaite avoir ce dossier un peu
derrière soi le chef de l'État a sans
doute d'autres ambitions pour son
deuxème mandat que d'avoir ce point sur
l'immigration s'il veut continuer à
vouloir incarner ce en même temps il va
bien falloir un moment donné qu'il
redresse un peu au centre qu'il parle de
sujets qui soi des sujet autre que de
sujet que de sujet régalien il a sans
doute C cet agenda en tête il nous a
annoncé une grande de quelque chose de
grand pour le début de l'année 2024 une
grande annonce ou quelque chose de très
important donc on imagine que pour lui
c'est très important qu'au vu du 31
décembre il puisse dire devant les
Françaises et les Français que la
démocratie a fonctionné que au fond dans
une situation sans majorité sa première
ministre est arrivé à trouver le le
compromis et donc d'envoyer un message
pour 2024 qui sont un message de
nouvelles réformes ou de nouveaux
objectifs c'est évidemment très très
très très très important on voit que du
côté des républicains il y a une une
forte forte forte très forte pression de
de cohérence c'est un mot qui est très
souvent utilisé par Bruno retaillot en
particulier et on voit que de leur côté
il s'agit de ne pas ouvrir la moindre
brèche dans l'idée que tel tel tel
élément viendrait remettre en cause
cette position de fermeté qu'ils ont on
va y revenir avec avec Mathieu sur le le
la stratégie DLR mais mais quand même
alors Salvin toujours sur le
gouvernement parce que depuis 48 he
c'est peut-être la méthode cé mais on a
on entend beaucoup de de de cadres de de
la majorité présidentielle ou du
gouvernement bah dire on est confiant
ouion les croire bah je pense qu'ils ont
bien raison de de dire ça par s'il
disait qu'ils étaient inquit ça sera un
petit peu on est assez d'accord voilà
mais ceci dit moi je reviens juste sur
sur un point que que Bruno soulignait je
pense que on est vraiment en plein
décalage entre ce que souhaiteraient les
Français ce ce à quoi ils pourraient
s'attendre et justement la volonté
présidentielle d'aller VI
de faire avancer les choses et cetera
les Français il faut quand même oublier
qu'ils sortent comme les Européens
d'ailleurs d'une période après covid
après conflits
internationaux après inflation massive
et cetera d'une crise sans précédent et
donc quand on les interroge les crises
succèdent aux crises exactement et quand
on les interroge on leur si on leur
demande est-ce qu'il faut qu'on continue
à avancer vite qu'on continue à réformer
le pays et cetera les Français sont
attendez faites une pause en fait on a
besoin de souffler et là on voit
qu'effectivement le Président il est
complètement en décalage avec les
Français mais quand je dis les Français
c'est aussi certainement les députés
parce que finalement les députés les
sénateurs sont des Français comme les
autres mais si si vous posez la question
de de de la confiance des effectivement
il peut pas dire autre chose mais elle
peut aussi ne pas être conclusive cette
commission mixte paritaire absolument
enfin à l'heure où on se parle c'est
encore une hypothèse c'est pas
l'hypothèse la plus la plus
évidente mais c'est une hypothèse c'est
une hypothèse comme effectivement alors
j'avoue que dans les mémoires des surs
on a souvent aussi le avril en tête
voilà ça ça ça reste il ne faut pas
sauter le premier tour en fait hein et
là effectivement c'est encore il est
encore possible que ça n'arrive pas
est-ce qu'ils disent ça par prophétie
autoréalisatrice je sais pas en tout cas
c'est sûr qu'ils ont envie aussi d'y
croire pourquoi parce que sil n'y croit
pas en fait on peut là pour le coup
c'est un vrai une vraie crise plus
qu'une crise démocratique c'est une
crise gouvernementale monumentale et
effectivement avec des conséquences qui
risquent d'être beaucoup plus larges que
seulement euh euh comment dire la
démission de la première ministre par
exemple ou de ou de Gérald Arman bon
donc on est au soir du premier tour si
je vous si je vous ents bien du premier
tour exactement Mathieu les LR parlons
des LR ils tiennent leur revanche oui
c'est un peu Noël avantleheure pour éc
CTI et ses lutin la droite avait démarré
l'année de la pire des manières
souvenez-vous avec la réforme des
retraites qui avait jeté une lumière
crue sur ses divisions internes sur son
absence de responsabilité sur son
absence de crédibilité sur son absence
de fiabilité pour secourer la mémoire
courte je rappelle quand même que la
droite dont tous les candidats
promettait depuis 20 ans la retraite à
65 ans et dont les sénateurs votaient
chaque année une proposition de lo en ce
sens avait fini par se débiner
piteusement à l'Assemblée pour un projet
de loi qui ramenait la retraite à 64 ans
et les voilà aujourd'hui donc cette
droite qui était un peu déconfite
décomposés dictant leur ligne sur ce
projet de loi immigration une ligne dure
on l'a dit en l'occurrence tenant leur
mains tenant dans leur mains pardon la
majorité qui est bien obligée de
composer le tout au prix de manœuvre
politicienne certes mais mais comme on
dit au football seul le résultat compte
et l'histoire retiendra donc que c'est
leur texte qui s'impose quand même pas
mal pour un parti qui n'avait pas
dépassé la barre des 5 % à la dernière
présidentielle et qui compte le groupe
parlementaire le plus familique de son
histoire à l'Assemblée Seris sur le
gâteau ils sont même parvenu à faire
mordre la psière un ancien transfuge qu'
s'était mis à détester gerérald daran
est-ce que pour autant on peut parler
d'une victoire sur toute la ligne bah
tout ceci n'est pas gratuit quand même
et pour les LR l'addition euh peut quand
même être assez salée d'abord je le
disais sur la forme les cûpts tactiques
successifs d'accord ça se révèle payant
au final mais ça soulligne quand même
quoi qu'on dise Bruno rotillot une une
absence de cohérence ou de fiabilité
pour cette formation politique qui était
quand même un ancien parti de
gouvernement sur le fond ensuite en
décalquant un grand nombre pour ne pas
dire la totalité des propositions du RN
en matière d'immigration les LR ont pris
le risque de se lancer dans une forme de
surenchère qui pourrait se révéler à
terme mortifère les lecteur finissant
toujours par préférer l'original à la
copie selon l'expression consacrée de
leupen paire et puis depuis qu'elle a
été chassée du pouvoir en 2012 la droite
n'a pas travaillé elle n'offre ni regard
neuf sur les évolutions de la société ni
de solution nouvelles pour répondre aux
enjeux actuels ou futur autant d'impasse
que leur victoire sur ce texte
d'immigration qui était quand même je le
rappelle encore un copiercollé de
beaucoup de propositions de de Marine Le
Pen mais autant de autant autant
d'impasse que cette victoire ne serait
masqué est-ce qu'elle a su reconstituer
son unité alors oui pour ce qui est ici
au Sénat mais ça reste encore démontré à
l'Assemblée où son groupe reste éclaté
entre les
macroomatibles vous souvenez des 17
signataires d'une tribune il y a 15
jours dans la presse les légitimist
c'estàdire ceux qui obéissent encore à
Eric cotti et Olivier marlex et les
auto-entrepreneurs comme le député du
Lot Aurélien Pradier qui votent comme ça
leur chante y compris sur la partition
est différente raison pour laquelle le
vote de demain sera particulièrement
scruté dans la majorité mais aussi chez
les LR alors on va parler ensemble des
LR avant ça vous avez cité évidemment
Bruno ta on est écoute une des dernières
réaction du du président du groupe LR
ici au Sénat si le texte sert de très
très près le texte du Sénat si la
boussole de ce texte c'est celui du
Sénat alors il n'y aura pas de problème
ni au Sénat bien entendu ni à
l'Assemblée nationale il y aura une très
petite minorité qui pourrait soit
s'abstenir ou ne pas le voter très
franchement si c'est le texte du Sénat
le gouvernement met de son côté un atout
pour le vote ensuite à l'Assemblée
nationale
Rachel B Mathieu faisait référence à
l'original et à la copie et le au duel
entre LR et rassemblement national le RN
n'a qu'un représentant dans cette dans
cette CMP il y a là une opportunité pour
pour le parti LR pour les républicains
bien sûr je Seris moins sévère c'est je
ne dirais pas que les républicains n'ont
pas travaillé au contraire là où ils ont
une carte majeure à jouer et qu'il joue
c'est qu'il ne laisse pas le monopole de
la droite à Emmanuel Macron c'était ça
le risque pour lesr cétait d'être
complètement liquidé justement après ce
qu'on peut qualifier de fiasco ou
d'échec à la campagne présidentielle or
il ne se laisse pas faire alors d'cuns
diront c'est peut-être le dernier échamp
du signe mais toujours est-il que au
Sénat ils ont travaillé et que boruno
rotao travaille également ses question
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas avec lui
c'est un fin connaisseur il y a des gens
comme stéphanini derrière qui sont des
experts he de de ces
questionsl la par exemple la est-ce
est-ce qu'ils font exister pardon nous
interrompe est-ce qu'ils font exister
une ligne sensiblement différente Simp
ce sur quoi insistait math de de celle
du rassemblement national alors si vous
voulez bien sûr qu'il y a des sujets il
y a des points qui viennent qui vient de
se croiser mais c'est eux par exemple
qui ont profité de leur niche
parlementaire pour tenter de dénoncer
les fameux accords franco-algériens dont
on a pas mal parlé c'est eux aujourd'hui
qui décident de se lancer contre l'aide
médicale d'État en la réduisant on va
dire à de l'aide médicale d'urgence
prog bien sûr ensuite est-ce que qui a
commencé qui est le premier c'est c'est
autre chose mais on on les entend quand
même beaucoup sur les sur les titres sur
les titres sur les régularisations sur
les on entend quand même beaucoup la
droite ensuite expliquer que qui copie
l'in qui copiutre c'est peut-être qu'on
a tout simplement oublié que c'est l'ADN
de la droite d'avoir ce type de position
dans l'histoire de la droite c'est pas
des positions qui sont complètement
exotiques et qui sont folkloriques ça
fait partie de cet ADN là et peut-être
que jusque là on l'avait oublié mais il
se rappelle au bons souvenir des
politiques de gauche ou du centre
Bruno cotres est-ce que les électeurs du
rassemblement national ou les sympathies
du du parti LR ou les sympathisants LR
va élargir ils attendent une sorte de
preuve d'efficacité sur cette question
de très important oui c'est très
important d'abord il faut rappeler que
toutes les enquêtes d'opinion montrent
que les sympathisants des républicains
sur ces questions sont aujourd'hui plus
proche des sympathisants rassemblement
national que des sympathisants
Renaissance le parti présidentiel c'est
pas la même chose sur l'économie sur les
questions régaliennes c'est clairement
ce qui se passe et effectivement il y a
la question de l'efficacité parce que
prouvez-nous que vous pouvez peser quoi
prouvez-nous que vous vous pouvez peser
mais il y aura aussi la question de
l'efficacité de ces mesures entre
aujourd'hui l'élection présidentielle
parce que un effet inattendu de ce qui
est en train de se passer pourrait être
par exemple d'obliger du coup le
rassemblement national à se extrémiser à
nouveau sur ces questions on a beaucoup
dit que Éric Zemour avait centrer Marine
Le Pen et cetera mais si au fond les
républicains aujourd'hui ont des
positions qui étaient avant cell du
rassemblement national est-ce que ça ne
va pas conduire le rassemblement
national dans la perspective de 2027 de
se entre guillemets radicaliser sur ces
sur ces questions dans une logique de
concurrence avec Zemour qui sera tout
qui sera toujours là sans aucun doute ou
Marion maréchal et donc ça c'est
peut-être le vrai Paris stratégique que
font les républicains de dire il faut
qu'on réoccupe effectivement ça de
manière à rebasculer le rassemblement
national vers des positions qui vont
apparaître trop extrêmes pas compatible
avec l'exercice du gouvernement alors on
parlait de la de la gauche une réaction
justement d'une sénatrice socialiste la
sénatrice socialiste de Paris
Marie-Pierre de de la Gonterie pour elle
la droite s'est couchée devant le
rassemblement national on l'écoute la
droite s'est couchée devant le Front
national c'est-à-dire que on l'a vu au
Sénat la droite sénatoriale la droite
française qui a une tradition pourtant
par rapport à cela a décidé de rompre
cette digue qui existait encore et de
mettre en place effectivement tous les
dispositifs à sa disposition de mise en
place d'une d'une préférence nationale
et ce qui est assez inquiétant c'est de
voir
qu'effectivement le gouvernement semble
vouloir un texte quel que soit son
contenu même si la droite décide de
dériver vers cette extrême droite et ce
qui est assez curieux bien évidemment
c'est la position des macronistes nous
verrons tout à l'heure mais c'est aussi
la position des centristes don ce n'est
pas l'histoire h pierre de la gonrie qui
participe à cette commission mixte
paritaire lors Salvin comment les
Français perçoivent justement ce thème
d'immigration d'abord est-ce que c'est
remonté dans les préoccupations des
Français peut-être à la faveur de cette
de cette actualité et ensuite
effectivement est-ce qu'ils ont le
sentiment d'une d'une gauche inaudible
ou d'une droite trop proche du
rassemblement national comment vous
l'avez analyser ça en fait effectivement
on voit depuis plusieurs mois que le
sujet de l'immigration remonte au niveau
vous voyez à peu près de 2015 de la
crise la crise migratoire donc là
aujourd'hui bah dans la dernière enquête
que nous avons réalisé pour la
Commission européenne justement c'est la
troisème préoccupation des Français euh
derrière le pouvoir d'achat et et et la
santé alors qu'il y a encore quelques
années c'était plutôt dans les 56èm
préoccupations donc là il y a vraiment
un un un enjeu euh le problème moi je
dirais pour les Français c'est de savoir
de quoi on parle quand on parle du sujet
de l'immigration est-ce qu'on parle du
sujet de l'immigration clandestine et en
gros les Français quand on leur pose la
question de l'immigration c'est vraiment
en numéro 1 ce qui arrive euh est-ce
qu'on parle de l'intégration et ça ça
arrive plutôt en 3oème position est-ce
que ça est-ce qu'on parle de du coût
économique vous voyez il y a plein de
sujets et plein de ramifications sur ce
sujet de de l'immigration donc
aujourd'hui les français ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on voit dans dans les
enquêtes d'opinion ce monde beaucoup
plus radicaux qu'il y a quelques années
sur tout tout ce qui est régulation
contrôle sortie du du territoire et
retour aux frontière et là en ce sens on
pourrait dire que l'opinion des Français
est plutôt et de plus en plus d'accord
d'ailleurs avec les idées du
rassemblement national vous savez on
vient de
sortir le le le baromètre de l'image du
rassemblement national pour le le monde
et franceino et justement c'est la
première année depuis 84 où il y a on a
une majorité de Français qui considèrent
que le RN n'est pas un danger pour la
démocratie euh et donc effectivement
quand on dit et quand les les les les
différents hommes et femmes politiques
disent effectivement le risque c'est que
finalement on fasse le jeu du RN ou que
on en arrive à à à calquer les positions
de des républicains sur celle du du RN
mais en fait pour les Français une
majorité de Français ça pose pas
forcément de problème donc c'est là
aussi où il faut qu'on fasse attention à
nos arguments parce qu'on risque aussi
de stigmatiser une partie de la
population qui ne va pas comprendre
pourquoi on utilise tel et tel argum
alors que c'est pas du tout en Phe avec
ce qu'il pens non je parlais d'identité
politique je parlais pas de j'avais pas
d'anathème mot il se trouve que c'est un
projet qui est quand même très très à
droite et dont beaucoup de propositions
figuraient je le rappelle dans dans le
le le le programme de Marine Le Pen
alors oui c'est vrai que vous avez
raison de souligner que brune rotillot
est un fin connaisseur de de de ces
problématiques d'immigration je disais
il y a pas non plus une nouvelle
approche il y a pas non plus de
nouvelles mesures les seules mesures qui
sont sorties sont les mesures de
durcissement des conditions actuelles
qui existaient alors que ce soit toit
sur la déchéance de nationalité par
exemple c'est ça existe dans le droit
français c'est c'est appliqué au
comptegoutte alors là on veut le faire
pour les pour les auteurs de crimes
contre les représentants des forces de
l'ordre mais g Marine Le Pen était
beaucoup l'avait aussi dans son dans son
programme que ce soit sur la préférence
nationale et c'est vrai que cette
problème d'allocation sociale qui est je
rappelle que ça concerne les les
étrangers en situation régulière qui
travaill qui ne pourrait les toucher que
au bout de 5 ans dans la version de la
droite ce qui le cas pour le RSA mais ce
qui est pas le cas forcément pour toutes
les les autresoc notamment les
allocations dit contributives c'estàd
celle pour laquelle quand on est salarié
on cotise et on devrait pouvoir avoir
droit enfin ça ça crée une différence
entre le fait qu'on soit français ou
étranger bref donc une forme de
préférence nationale tout ça est quand
même teinté on peut je le dis pas d'un
point de vue moral encore une fois
chacun peut avoir ses convictions mais
d'un point de vue originalité c'est
c'est quand même très très teinté c'est
là où l'explication alors elle convint
ou elle convent pas de Bruno rotillot
notamment là-dessus et est assez fine
c'està-dire qu'il déplace euh il se
justifie d'une autre manière il ne va
pas dire bien sûr mais nous dragons un
électorat qui était jusquelà perdu ou
alors nous répondons à des attentes dans
nos circonscriptions que que que l'on
peut qui peuvent remonter il dit et
c'est malin c'est euh le résultat d'une
comparaison européenne quand on compare
la France aux autres pays de l'Union
européenne on se rend compre sur la me
sur le regrouement familial sur les
conditions de langue et cetera qu'on
fait partie des pays les moins exigeants
ou les plus souple et c'est pour une
mise à niveau
ave exactement pour une mise à niveau
avec l'ensemble de nos voisins que l'on
temps vers ce type de mesure c'est assez
malin dans l'argumentation
Bruno voilà il y a la face d'argument et
puis il y a quelque chose qui est
vraiment très important qui revient chez
lui sans cesse qui est cette exigence de
de cohérence voilà et donc d'où l'idée
de faire monter les enchères par exemple
sur laame et on voit bien que sur la
question de laame il y a la fois la
volonté pour les républicains de ne pas
apparaître un jour comme entre
guillemets les dindons de la phare
c'est-à-dire d'avoir aidé le
gouvernement aujourd'hui pour découvrir
dans quelques semaines que sur la me au
fond ça ne va pas du tout dans les
directions souhaitées par les
républicains et puis la question de la
cohérence parce que beaucoup d'électeur
de droite ont dit bah finalement quand
la droite était au pouvoir elle faisait
pas les idées de la droite Nicolas
Sarkozy a beaucoup reçu ses critiques
après 2012 beaucoup de de sympathisants
des républicains disaient bah voilà la
la droite elle ne sait pas appliquer les
mesures de la droite quand qu elle quand
elle gouverne donc on voit que c'est une
question effectivement de retisser une
identité politique pour les républicains
ils adoptent une stratégie politique
assez classique dans la vie politique et
ce qu'on appelle la triangulation aller
chercher dans le camp d'en face ou chez
ses concurrents des arguments solelérés
appropriés après il faut la crédibilité
eux ils sont encore perçus quand même
par l'électorat comme un parti qui parle
de la loi de l'ordre de la sécurité donc
c'est c'est c'est pas c'est pas une
triangulation si incohérente que ça HM
alors vous parliez de l'aide médicale
d'État effectivement euh euh les LR ont
fait monter en quelque sorte les
enchères avec le gouvernement sur sur ce
thème il réclamait un engagement écrit
de la première ministre pour euh
réformer cette ame au mois de janvier
c'estàd elle serait sortie du texte là
discuté en CMP pour être
euh consacré avec un texte en soit au
mois de janvier écoutez sur ce thème la
députée LR Annie Genevard qui participe
à la commission mixte paritaire l'ame
l'aide médicale d'État est en effet ce
qu'on appelle un cavalier législatif il
est pas tout à fait dans le périmètre de
la loi mais en même temps le problème
est est très important aujourd'hui les
Français ont du mal à se soigner et
comprendrai mal que certains soient
traités notamment les étrangers en
situation irrégulière accède au même
panier de soins que même pour lesquels
c'est c'est devenu difficile donc ce
sujet est très important la première
ministre s'est engagé à écrire à nous
écrire pour nous dire dire que ça ferait
l'objet d'un texte dédié sur la base du
rapport Stéphanie nievvin bon
aujourd'hui ce que nous voulons ce que
nous attendons dans cette lettre c'est
que le gouvernement s'engage à réformer
laame non pas pour en élargir le
périmètre mais pour en diminuer
précisément le périmètre lettre
qu'Élisabeth borne a envoyé à Gérald
armanin dans l'après-midi elle s'engage
à ce que il y ait un texte j'ai dit
Gérard Larcher merci beaucoup Elsa
dariula qui est la réctrice en chef de
l'émission qui m'a immédiatement corrigé
merci Elsa heureusement que que tu es là
euh donc envoyer à Gérard Larcher
évidemment et ça n'est pas du tout la
même chose engagement à mettre ce cette
réforme de la me au programme dès le
mois de janvier peut-être Rachel bignas
parce que notre débat il est beaucoup
sur la stratégie politique mais aussi
sur le contenu du texte vous disiez tout
à l'heure la France est
peut-être la plus souple des pays
européens c'est vrai aussi pour laame si
on comp par ce qui existe ailleurs
l'aide médicale d'État alors il y a un
rapport publié en 2019 par l'Inspection
des finances et des affaires sociales
qui notait que nous étions alors je cite
l'un des pays les plus généreux de
l'Union européenneon sans doute le le
plus généreux pour plein de raisons on
ne met plus depuis 2012 en place un
ticket modérateur comme ça a pu être le
cas c'est le cas en Espagne ça peut être
le cas également en Italie c'est plus le
cas et en effet on a un panier de soins
qui ressemble fortement au panier de
soins du cotisant classique traditionnel
à ce titre on ne se contente pas de
l'AMU l'aide médicale d'urgence nous on
étant on est on est bien plus généreux
deux chiffres sans sans noyer le le
téléspectateur mais qui permet de
montrer un petit peu l'évolution et les
et les enjeux parce que depuis ça
création c'est exactement c'était quand
1999 2000 on va dire 99 2000 on doit ça
à Martin aub et Gérard couchner environ
80000 personnes ont bénéficié à cette
époque pour un coût de 139 millions
d'euros aujourd'hui on atteint environ
ont 400000 euh bénéficiaires pour une
dépense d'environ 1,2 milliard d'euros
c'est le milliard le plus scruté euh de
France par notamment par notamment la
droite c'est un enjeu extrêmement
important le gouvernement au départ ne
souhaitait pas mettre ce sujet sur la
table il y a 1 an un an et demi au début
de la loi asile immigration et puis bah
maintenant la droite pousse elle
travaille dessus depuis un certain
nombre d'années je pense au rapport par
exemple de Véronique louvagie député de
Lorne euh qui euh publie des rapports
sur ce sujet c'est le un point de
crispation extrêmement important au sein
même de la macronie alors ce qui est
passionnant bah justement sur sur les
enjeux de cette fin d'après-midi c'est
qu'il y a d'abord vous dit premier tour
ce soir cette commission mixte paritaire
c'est toujours suspendu hein d'ailleurs
est-ce qu'elle sera conclusive ensuite
bon imaginons qu'elle le soit il y a le
deuxième tour à l'Assemblée et au Sénat
de demain pour voir si le texte va être
voté ou pas et sil va fracturer euh la
la majorité présidentielle mais on peut
même la aajouter un troisème tour avec
avec ce texte sur l'aide médicale d'État
en janvier parce que les les mêmes
causes produiront les les mêmes effets
alors Salvin c'estàd que cette c'est
c'est cette ce risque de de d'implosion
au sein même de Renaissance on va voir
une peut-être une réponse demain il y en
aura une autre en janvier absolument et
je suis pas sûr effectivement que le
gouvernement avait mesuré à quel point
ce sujet était explosif je me souviens
il y a un petit peu moins d'un an on
discutait on on finalisait les retraites
on discutait ici des retraites de la
façon dont le gouvernement a mis en
place les retraites et l'immigration
arrivé à bas bruit et et et et justement
on disait en fait ils sont en train de
de de refaire les mêmes erreurs que sur
les retraites c'est-à-dire partir bille
en tête sur un texte sur des mesures
sans forcément expliquer et faire de la
pédagogie sur le projet de société qu'il
dessine à travers ce texte et là donc
moi c'est pas le en même temps qui me
gêne c'est le le en même temps sans sens
sans sens vous voyez c'estàd que là sans
cap sans cap on voit pas effectivement
quel est le projet pour la société et
comme ce sont des sujets extrêmement
sensibles qui touchent à nos valeurs à
nos valeurs d'accueil d'identité et
cetera au moins le 3è tour de janvier
quelque part ou février il aura un seul
sens voy pourit aussi considérer alors
que le cap c'était justement d'avoir un
texte équilibré avec une partie incarnée
par Géral une autre par Olivier du sopte
enfin voilà en l'urence ça marche ça
donne
effectivement comment dire un
qualificatif à la réforme qui est
équilibré mais ça donne pas le sens
profond et puis surtout comment dire les
valeurs auxqueles il se rattache et moi
je crois que ce qui manque aujourd'hui
aux Français aussi c'est de pouvoir se
dire cette politique publique elle est
mise en place pour tel projet de société
et pour finalement la France d dans 10
ans quoi Mathie c'est quand même assez
habile cette histoire de sortir la me du
texte d'abord parce que il avit de
fortes Chan que ce soit censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel on entendait le
son le son de Danny johv qui rappelait
que c'est ce qu'on appelle un cavalier
législatif en quand un sujet n'a rien à
voir avec la
chouroutementit fait censurer ensuite
parce que oui Elisabeth borne a demandé
au ministre concerné comme elle le dit
dans son courrier de prendre des mesures
soit réglementaires soit législatives
pour réformer la me je dire si ce projet
se plante ça ça n'andquera pas le
gouvernement je il n'y tient pas comme à
la prunelle de ses yeux donc si la
majorité sindait en janvier sur un vote
ou un peu plus tard sur la réforme de
laame ça serait moins problématique pour
Emmanuel Macron que si ce projetlà ne
passe pas demain h alors il y a un autre
enjeu évidemment dans dans cette loi
combien de dans combien de débats on en
a on en a parlé de la régularisation des
étrangers qui travaillent dans des
secteurs en tension le ministre de
l'Intérieur il est revenu sur sur le
texte alors le texte retouché par les
sénateurs donc l'article 3 devenu
article 4 bis Gérald daran les étrangers
qui respectent la loi et qui travaill
sont les bienvenus dans la communauté
nationale les étrangers qui ne
respectent pas la loi qui sont des tueur
qui ne respectent pas les de la
République doivent être exclus du
territoire national ça ça sera la
discrétion du préfet donc il faut il
faut que l'on régularise il faut qu'on
accompagne ceux qui veulent travailler
en France qui travaillent dans nos
restaurants qui travaillent dans le BTP
qui travaillent durement dans
l'agriculture cela je pense qu'ils sont
les bienvenus dans la communauté
nationale et effectivement ce sera la
discrétion du préfet et dans les métiers
dit en tenstion tout le monde voit qu'il
y a des endroits où on arrient pas assez
à recruter et dans des zones
géographiques spécifiques et puis tous
ceux qui ne respectent pas de la
République doent être exclu ce texte il
prévoit quoi qu'on puisse régulariser la
nourrice celle qui travaille auprès de
vos enfants l'ingénieur le serveur le
médecin et puis qu'on puisse exclure
enfin le criminel et on retrouve
l'analyse du départ Mathieu 1 le méchant
avec les méchants et gentil avec les
gentils Rachel bignas il y a il y a aux
abonnés absents le patronat sur ce débat
c'est alors que le patronat on peut dire
n'a pas enfin j'allais dire a été tendre
avec le le gouvernement a été tendre
avec le patrona depuis le début du du
premier quinen Macron ça fait partie de
la la logique on va dire libérale du
président de la République et là ils
répondent pas présent au moment où ils
ont peut-être le plus besoin d'eux c'est
vrai c'est vrai alors on entend on peut
entendre on peut entendre certaines
branches s'exprimer on entendu la
restauration par exemple qui appel de
ses vœux une
régularisation ça peut permettre à
certaines branches pas seulement je
pense pas forcément à la restauration
mais de se faire l'économie d'une
réflexion sur ses propres conditions de
travail en se disant ben que une main
d'œvre justement extérieur à la France
pouvait être de bonne àoi so en effet le
le MDEF est assez discret et assez
discret depuis le le début alors il y a
eu des changements au sein aussi
de exactement qui se veut un peu plus
social disons et qui certainement a
n'est pas forcément convaincu par cette
immigration qui viendrait en France il
faut dire que on a certains rapports
hein là-dessus si on fait une petite
comparaison
payocde on a une immigration qui est
parmi la moins qualifiée de l'ensemble
des pays de l'OCDE donc qui peut avoir
des difficultés à s'intégré pour
beaucoup qui ne maîtrisent pas je pense
par exemple au demandeurs d'asile qui
obtiennent même l'asile qui ne
maîtrisent pas leur propre langue
maternelle en en écriture et en lecture
ce qui peut rendre compliqué
l'apprentissage du français donc toute
une partie du patronat explique de
manière plus ou moins officielle qu'elle
préférait quelque part que l'on forme
les Français qui sont aujourd'hui sans
qualification ou sans emploi plutôt que
faire venir une main d'œuvre qui ne
correspond peut-être pas aux besoins du
du marché mais en effet le seul moment
où on les a un tout petit peu entendu
c'est sur la question du français parce
qu'il était question et leur premier
réflexe a été de
s'opposer d'apprendre le français sur
les heures de travail leur premier
réflexe a été de dire non finalement ils
se sont assouplis là-dessus mais en
effet on peut pas dire qu'il marche main
dans la main avec le gouvernement qu'on
puisse dire euh Bruno C je reviens sur
le le dessin de Gérald Haran du ministre
de l'Intérieur qui a présenté sa
démission j'allais dire une première
fois à au président de la République
desmions refusé imaginons encore une
fois l'hypothèse n'est pas la plus
plausible mais que que cette commission
mixte paritaire a priori on va retourner
voir Quentin calm dans un instant mais
la suspension de séance dure assez
longtemps malgré manifestement imaginons
que cette CMP ne soit pas conclusive
qu'est-ce qui peut se passer derrière
est-ce que un Gérald Haran un peu euh
voilà sauter pardon du d'être un peu
trivial sur ce sur ce ce sur ce texte
cette absence de réforme certain c'est
qu'il ne pourrait pas présenter une
deuxième fois sa démission parce que là
elle serait bien évidemment accepté il
est impossible au chef de l'État deux
fois de refaire le même scénario on sait
que le chef de l'État n'aime pas agir
sur la composition du gouvernement dans
l'immédiat sous la contrainte voilà ça
donne le sentiment euh de dramatiser ça
donne le sentiment de reconnaître un
échec bien bien évidemment
euh j'imagine que si tel devait être le
cas ça ne peut être fait que dans une
recomposition un tout petit peu plus
large ça peut pas être simplement
enlever de mise l'intérieur parce que
même si on lui substituit quelqu'un
d'autre le problème politique reste
entier si jamais la CMP n'est pas
conclusive ça veut dire que l'accord n'a
pas pu être trouvé avec les républicains
et c'est pas le fait de remplacer le le
ministre actuel par un autre qui va
régler qui va régler le problème et lui
il est parmi les anciens républicains
qui travaillent avec Emmanuel Macron il
est quand même celui qui qui est le
mieux à même normalement de trouver cet
accord il a toujours investi les
questions de sécurité il a toujours
voulu incarner un positionnement dans le
droitfil de Nicolas Sarkozi sur ces sur
ces questions donc on s'imagine que si
lui n'y arrive pas on imagine mal
quelqu'un d'autre alors on on retourne à
l'Assemblée
nationale retourner voir Quentin calm
qui est avec audre vetaz et redem Rabit
sur place donc Quentin vous nous
confirmez que cette suspension de séance
qui est intervenue très très vite euh
elle elle
continue exactement ça fait plus d' 1h30
1h 40 même que cette suspension de la
réunion de la commission mixte paritaire
est en cours elle a duré effectivement 5
minutes cette réunion de la CMP au bout
de 5 minutes après l'appel en fait des
membres de la CMP il y a eu cette
suspension et leslr qui seraiit dans une
salle qui jxte la salle de la CMP pour
discuter entre eux et ce que l'on voit
depuis maintenant 30 30 minutes ce sont
des parlementaires de gauche qui se
succèdent ici en salle des en salle des
quatre Coles des quatre colonnes ici à
l'Assemblée nationale où les
journalistes sont réunis et ces
parlementaires de gauche que ce soit les
socialistes les communistes les
écologistes ils dénonc ce qui se joue
autour de cette CMP ils appellent même à
suspendre la CMP et à la reprendre après
les vacances de la suspension pour Noël
c'est le cas par exemple de Patrick
canner le président du groupe socialiste
au Sénat il a eu cette expression parce
qu'on lui demandait aussi est-ce que
c'est pas une mise en scène cette
suspension et ces desésaccords entre LR
et Renaissance il a dit si c'est un
théâtre d'ombre le spectacle n'a pas
encore commencé merci beaucoup Quentin
vous m'offrez la transition on va
écouter tout de suite le président du
groupe socialiste CNA Patrick caner
c'est un scandale je dire on a le les
administrations ont travaillé il y a eu
des négociations qui ont lieu pendant 4
jours avant la CMP et aujourd'hui on
voilà on commence par une suspension de
séance qui est encore en cours donc ce
n'est pas acceptable donc si la majorité
et la droite qui veulent un accord entre
eux ne sont pas d'accord qui reporte le
dossier et puis on se reverra plus tard
Bruno cotress les les les leaders de la
gauche s'expriment là dans la salle des
quatre colonnes mais il pèse pas
suffisamment lourd au sein de cette
commission mixte paritaire non
normalement cette commission mixte elle
est clairement dominée par le Centre le
centre droit à la droite voilà donc
effectivement la gauche regarde plutôt
en et c'est bizarre d'ailleurs la
réaction du sénateur caner qui demande à
ce qu'on remette ça au au lendemain
parce que évidemment on imagine bien que
si tel devait être le cas d'une certaine
manière ça enterre un petit peu le un
peu le dossier Emmanuel Macron a dit que
si ça passait pas en cmt en CMP pardon
de toute façon lui pensait plutôt
retirer son son projet alors Salvin
est-ce que c'est la capacité je continue
de de me projeter de d'Emmanuel Macron
finalement à réformer le pays qui est en
train de se jouer très clairement bah
absolument effectivement lui il a pour
ambition de continuer à à réformer le le
pays je pense qu'il va peut-être un
petit peu trop vite il va aller un petit
peu trop vite et là on voit bien même
plus largement que la réforme du pays je
pense que c'est aussi la
capacité à mettre en place des politique
publique qui puisse être voté dans un
parlement qui évidemment n'a pas la
majorité absolue et puis c'est aussi
également la capacité à trouver des
compromis et donc effectivement on le
rappelait des compromis ça peut des
compromis ça peut coûter cher la
capacité à trouver des compromis au cas
par cas euh avec les différents courants
politiques aujourd'hui en France je
pense que si on avait une dissolution
demain je pense que ça résoudrait pas
beaucoup euh la situation politique et
on n' pas encore trouvé vraiment la clé
justement pour pouvoir faire de la
politique autrement avec cette
configuration là qui est vraiment très
particulière merci beaucoup merci à tous
et et à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat